Morris is in Chicago hi Morris welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are
you sir better than I deserve what's up
yeah just a quick question for you I'm
currently on baby step to started about
nine months ago we've paid off 50,000
good for eighty seven thousand dollars
yay and I'm a little across roads with
me and my wife we have a CD degenerative
mature in a couple of months and I want
to use the rest of that money to be
debt-free but she doesn't because our
last loan that we have is a car loan the
general % and she just wants to keep
working the baby stuff until it's gone
in about six months
well she's not working the baby step
baby step - by definition is you use all
money that you have not counting
retirement to pay on the debt you should
have already cashed out this CD and put
it on the step well the reason I felt
like I didn't want to do it because of
the penalty that was in Vienna you
nothing so the penalty ain't nothing if
they kept all the interest they wouldn't
keep anything it's 1% it's a joke all
right it's a joke cash it out and pay
off your debt and just do so if I if I
cash it out early apply all of it to the
record that we have and then yep from
there then you go to baby step 3
well that's the thing we're kind of in
the middle of these two baby steps
because baby step three I feel like that
is our emergency fund you know you're
not on baby step three you still have
debt baby step two by definition what
we've taught for years in all of our
materials as you stop all investing you
take all savings and all assets that are
not in a retirement account cash them in
and throw them at your debt once you are
debt-free other than your home then you
are on baby step three there is no
circumstance in which we've ever
described the you are n baby step two
and three at the same time you're just
screwin
with a savings account and would sit out
instead of cashing that thing out and
paying off your debt that's all you're
doing and you need to you need to cash
it out today
and pay off your debt it's what I would
do you called and asked me now you and
your wife decide what you want to do but
that's what I would do
hey thanks for the call